[Music]
welcome back everyone its charlie we
have a brand new preview for Marvel
eternals movie they dropped a brand new
teaser they're almost done filming the
movie so we'll break it down
there was also an eternals trailer that
was shown off as Cece XP last month so
we'll also do a breakdown to that
footage after I talk about this brand
new preview this is a really cool Easter
Egg in some of the Eternals characters
that ties back to a really big guardians
of the galaxy scene and there's another
really cool Doctor Strange Easter Egg so
you can kind of see how they're using
the Eternals to provide this common
point of origin for a lot of the design
language and a lot of the way people's
powers work in present day so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's gonna be a bunch of crazy stuff
coming up really soon we have the Super
Bowl next week too at a bunch of Super
Bowl trailers this really cool teaser
just shows off Richard Madden's Icarus
character in his full celestial armor
with his powers activated the design of
his armor is a little bit more like the
ornate blend of Iron Man's more recent
nano armors and Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame in the Asgardian
armors and design language that you see
with people like Thor and Odin I'll talk
about the Doctor Strange Easter Egg in a
second too because it involves some of
the way their powers work this also ties
a little bit to the powers that people
get from Infinity stones but the
Eternals were made by the Celestials the
second most ancient beings in the
universe so their designs are based on
celestial design language if you see any
kind of similarities in Thor Asgardian
design language or their armor their
weapons buildings in a lot of that stuff
on earth it's because everyone is
inspired by the Celestials in some way
they have this ancient hand in shape
being the way the universe developed
which I'll talk about in a second the
really cool Easter egg here you notice
here especially for the Infinity stones
is the way Richard Madden's powers work
with that light bloom of energy you see
growing from his fist it's also very
similar to the look of Captain Marvel's
infinity stone based energy when she's
using her powers most of his powers
through the Eternals comics have been
pretty consistent the movie itself is
based on Neil Gaiman 's Eternals run
from 2006 there was a miniseries I'll
explain a little bit of that too in a
second but there's a connection here in
his powers Captain Marvel got her powers
from the space stone and the tesseract
the Eternals get their different powers
from the Celestials imbuing them with
the same type of cosmic energy that the
Infinity stones contain remember that
guardians of the galaxy flash back
with Isan the searcher using the power
stone eternity the living embodiment of
the multiverse creates Celestials to go
out and garden itself garden the planets
to try and create life every couple
million years the celestial host comes
to see how their experiment has borne
fruit or how its failed if they consider
it a failure they wipe the slate clean
and destroy all life on the planet and
start over again with a new experiment
somewhere else remember during guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 ego the Living
Planet is a celestial Peter quill is
half celestial he's actually doing an
extreme version of that because he's
trying to terraform of the entire
universe to become part of him so
whatever planet this used to be this is
east on the searcher coming to say that
this experiment did not pan out so we're
just gonna kill all life on this planet
and start over again somewhere else so
it's no coincidence that those same
Celestials that came to Planet Earth as
part of the celestial host used infinity
stone energy to create the Eternals so
that's why a lot of their powers will
look similar to the powers you've seen
from recent people in the last couple of
Avengers movies remember the guardians
of the galaxy infinity stone scene where
the collector is showing them the
flashback of the six ancient people
trying to share the power of the
Infinity stones before being destroyed
by that power those people were eternals
not the Eternals were gonna see during
the movie because obviously they're
still alive and those Eternals were
wiped out by the power of the stones but
when the Celestials created the Eternals
there were a lot of different groups of
them living all over the earth thousands
and thousands of years ago after a
couple civil wars some of them decided
to leave led by Thanos his father Alaris
as named by Red Skull Thanos son of uh
Lars to colonize the planet Titan
millennia later
danos was born tiny baby Thanos this was
actually concept art created for a young
version of Thanos that we're gonna show
you in a flashback that wound up being
in Avengers infinity war deleted scene
it never made it past the concept stage
but this is basically what he would have
looked like when he was much much
younger so don't expect to see tiny baby
Thanos during the first Eternals movie
but if it goes well and they do a
trilogy maybe we'll see tiny baby Thanos
and one of those sequels one of the
crazier things about the Eternals I
don't know if they're gonna include this
in the movie but it's a big part of the
Neil Gaiman run that the movie is based
on is that when they die they actually
reincarnate there's a special celestial
3d print
that prints them a new body and just
transplants their consciousness into it
so if something was wrong with them
before they died it gets fixed because
it just reprints them from their
original genome so a lot of you have
asked how come the Eternals didn't help
out during Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame like I said as they're
basing this on the Neil Gaiman run
they've had their minds wiped so they
didn't know that they were Eternals they
just thought that they were normal
people going about their days the whole
idea with the Eternals movie is that
something happens they realize how
everything has changed after avengers
endgame and that's what brings them out
of hiding the deviants are the villains
of the movie they're also the villains
of the comic book they try to take
advantage of some of the celestial of
technology the Eternals been try to move
to help humanity out but here's a
breakdown of the Eternals trailer from
CC XP last month the Kevin Feige brought
and showed off so drew that opens these
doors of what looked like a training
camp he finds part of the Eternals
reunited with Richard Madden's Icarus
character at the front he stares at them
and says welcome feel at home then there
are a bunch of different scenes of the
different main characters from the
Eternals being shown all over planet
Earth being worshipped by people as gods
then there's a new scene where they all
appear together in their special
celestial uniforms led by Salma Hayek's
a Jack character there's a bunch of
quick cuts of them all gathering around
a bonfire Angelina Jolie's FINA
character appears by the fire Salma
Hayek's Ajax character riding on
horseback
they keep jumping to different scenes
all over the planet that all featured
Jemma Chan's Circe character one of the
main characters of the movie then when
they all come together on the beach
around that bonfire Gemma Chan's Circe
character class Lea McHugh's sprite
character and what appears to be this
really special embrace the trailer then
ends with Salma Hayek's Ajax character
saying the people have changed us we
need to protect them there's a little
bit of footage from present-day with
Kumail Nanjiani 'he's Kingo character in
what seems like a Bollywood sequence
like he becomes a Bollywood star not
knowing that he's secretly an eternal
like the other characters but for the
most part the early trailer that they
showed off it just meant to show you the
history of their characters across
planet earth how they influenced a lot
of cultures how they used to be
worshipped as gods this movie and this
franchise however many sequels they do
will sort of be the history of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we've gotten a
little bit of that peppered throughout
the different films but this will just
be the deep dive into that and show
how everything is connected Asgardians
people on planet earth the Infinity
stones everything in speaking of
everything's connected if you look at
Psalm 'hi acts Ajax character in this
preview here just this early teaser of
what our costume and her powers are
going to look like notice down here at
her hand it looks like she's using a
glyph like the magic glyphs that dr.
strange uses when he's actually casting
spells so just another detail sort of
tying what they were doing thousands of
years ago to what's happening in present
day with the current Marvel Cinematic
Universe characters I know I haven't
talked much about kit harington's Black
Knight character but they haven't
included him in a lot of the trailer
footage yet he's one of the main
characters of the film's so he is really
important to the story but a lot of the
mythology for his character actually
comes from the Avengers comics where he
and Cersei had a romance they crossed
over with the Avengers a whole bunch the
reports about his character during the
movie is that he does have the Black
Knight origin story as the special evany
blade his special armor that comes from
his family but within the context of the
movie in present-day post Avengers
endgame he's an archaeologist who just
happens to discover the tomb of the
space gods which is something from the
Jack Kirby original eternals comics as
the name implies the tomb of the space
gods is just a special celestial base
that they left behind when they created
the Eternals that could wipe out
humanity so this sort of where he starts
crossing over with the Eternals
characters and then eventually a romance
develops with the Circe character like
he has in the comics it sounds like they
have big plans for his character to join
a future Avengers roster and whatever
the next Avengers movie winds up being
we just heard Kit Harington yes he's a
really amazing actor and this part came
up in the Eternals film that we're doing
we were so happy when he agreed to join
it and it is a part that could perhaps
grow into something else in the future I
could totally see them pitching Kit
Harington on doing this weird Eternals
movie which could be totally cool but
also on the idea that eventually he
would get to join a future Avengers
movie you also notice that Kit Harington
and Richard Madden are in a project
together again they haven't been
together on screen and say like 10 years
Robb Stark and Jon Snow really didn't
share any scenes after Game of Thrones
season 1 episode 2 she's very kind
next time I see you you'll be all in
black it was always my color farewell
snow and you start so it'll be really
cool to see them on screen together
again I can only imagine what the memes
are going to be like because the Black
Widow movie is being released in May I'm
expecting that's when they'll release
the first eternals teaser trailer but if
I get any news about that I'll include
it in a future video and if we have any
big surprise footage drops we have that
giant infinity Saga box that giveaway
that's still going on there was a bunch
of other stuff that just happened I'll
try to make videos for all that stuff as
quickly as possible
everyone click here for my brand new
Avengers evil Captain America teaser
breakdown and click here to learn all
about Doctor Strange - in x-men stuff
going on around Scarlet Witch thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]